y mención con honores la favorita de las
primarias populares efectivamente
terminó la primera de la clase frente a
sus partidarios la ex ministra de
justicia prometió reunir a todos sus
compañeros en el banco de la izquierda
se forma nuestro destino común reclama
unión y convivencia así que les diré con
respeto que conozco sus reticencias pero
también su inteligencia y su sentido del
interés general ante ellos
para unir a la izquierda detrás de su
nombre cristian tula tienen la intención
de llamar al ecologista y anillados la
socialista anne hidalgo el líder de
france insumisión lukman en sión y el
comunista fabián güzel según los últimos
sondeos ninguno de ellos puede
clasificarse en solitario para la
segunda vuelta pero todos ellos han
vuelto a declinar la idea de una alianza
denunciando una candidata más de la
izquierda
el partido franz sin su me dice que es
el que ha obtenido la mejor puntuación
en las últimas elecciones presidenciales
y los mejores sondeos así que le toca a
jean-luc mélenchon luego tienes a gianni
que adopte los verdes que dice hemos
ganado en todas las elecciones recientes
hay una emergencia ecológica y el medio
ambiente es la nueva matriz de la
izquierda por último está el partido
socialista que dice históricamente la
gente siempre nos apoya así que tienes
tres candidatos que dicen si estoy a
favor de la unidad pero detrás de mí
y
las primarias populares reunieron a casi
400.000 votantes por el sistema de
mención privó a cristian toby gad de una
victoria numérica por lo tanto es
imposible saber qué distancia la separa
del segundo y yannick jadot que a pesar
de su negativa a participar en la
votación obtuvo un resultado bastante
bueno